you're a pro skater you left ohio you
got a car you're getting a a paycheck
what do you want to do with that well
you got to understand like the other
side of my life is i was raised by
entrepreneurs right so the guy who
started the alien workshop was a 19 year
old serial entrepreneur who owned the
skate shop that i made a call to when i
was 11 years old who had a ramp in the
backyard and said if i get 10 people to
pay can i escape for free and he's like
what like why don't you just come down
here we'll let you skate and who is this
person his name is jimmy george and then
he
ice skated that ramp and that's he was
the first person to be like if that's
the first time you skated a ramp then
you are have a lot of potential i didn't
know what the word meant but they
sponsored me by the skate shop right
there from a cold call
to
being allowed to skate for free to
skating once to then them sponsoring me
on the spot so that's really when it
really never skated a ramp before never
and because there was no ramps in ohio
that was the only one so you were a
street skater right street skater and
really even those are mini ramps so not
like tony hawk style ramps but
if you can imagine then i watched him
start company after company then when i
turned pro it was for the alien workshop
where they all came back and built the
company with him so i thought
the really the first thing i was going
to do is start a company so no sooner
did i move to san diego then i then i
put together
the five best skateboarders in the world
and and came up with a concept called
orion aluminum and then i went to one of
the local manufacturers in san diego and
pitched them this concept of building a
company with me
and that i had these five best
skateboarders in the world that would be
on the team and that's when i launched
my first company at 17. so what was that
and that's called what orion aluminum it
was in the truck company like the
skateboard truck just the truck just
like the wheels underneath yeah no
wheels just the metal part that hold the
wheels and goes to the wood like the
accessory if you will so
that was like the very first because in
my mind i watched all these people
create all these companies all these
these years but wasn't weren't they just
skateboard companies where you buy a
skateboard like yeah oh they're fashion
brands and some were clothing bra or
some were skateboard brands there was a
skate shop i watched them do skateboard
contests but just the truck seems to be
so myopic it's so like yeah and that
makes a difference in the ride like did
you did you have an idea for how you
wanted a manufacturer to make it better
and stand out i i did does that make
sense yeah yeah but that's a stupid
question dad no that's a smart question
no it's not it's stupid
right you gotta innovate you gotta
create white space to have a successful
business but i'm saying i i agree with
you i'm saying that like i don't know
anything about i'm not a skateboarder
but like any sport i was just in a
tennis store yesterday and i saw some
woman come in that was so specific about
the strings on like the racket and
anyone like me would be like what it
doesn't make a difference but i think if
you're really into any sport every
little aspect of it makes a huge
difference right including the trucks
and look it does well then i am stupid i
did i just think that as a 17 year old
boy i think how can i get a skateboard
or i'm going to make my own skateboard
yeah well i already have my signature
skateboard right so when you turn pro
you get you get your own alien workshop
signature skateboard so i had that
and then really i looked at like what's
my opportunity to create a business
right and i couldn't create something
that conflicted with the alien workshop
and the boards and i was sponsored by
another
uh truck company and i looked at the
opportunity to really it was a marketing
play over innovation play where i had
the five best skateboarders in the world
and then we all got pieces of the
company and then i put the whole thing
together
and built that company's first company
that i built what's amazing to me is how
did you get the five best skateboarders
in the world to come follow you who's 17
years old at the time i'm sure they had
other opportunities
[Laughter]
[Music]
and answer me if i'm right the five best
skateboarders are all around 17 years
old and if you say let's get together
yeah let's uh let's uh uh approach this
company and we can all own a piece of
yeah i love that every time we ask a
question we're both just answering
can i be honest with you jackie you're
an idiot
oh man you guys are so lucky you guys
are so lucky
[Music]